so we are all here discussed what give
me thumbs would be like if it were
actually mean girl
I feel like Game of Thrones maybe just
is Mean Girls and we haven't realized it
until now who do you think would play
the obvious one Lannister they are the
same person
anyone been personally victimized by
[Music]
does anyone have the case for Virginia
Georgia being anybody but maybe didn't
there is if she knows all mad queens she
could be found like a Regina George type
but and we are all in agreement
Regina is the mathlete Kevin Evan I
think Kevin would be yyur on because
he's just like that irrational
confidence guys rolls into King's
Landing and it's like seriously what uh
totally I could see you're unwrapping if
they was like let's go go that all right
prep about having to good I'm not a
regular mom it's okay for gay you guys
so much by the way
Hades Jon Snow at this point kind of the
hero of the story much like Katie or
maybe if Daenerys would be Cady heron
because starts off with good intention
so that's how long she came from an
outside place she's nothing so like
adapt to this man right she's like the
ragtag friends Katie is an obvious
Daenerys who would be the other plastics
like
Gretchen and carrots and plastics are
the lannisters Jamie might turn on his
sister like that's kind of a little bit
foreshadowing right now is he gonna be
like Gretchen and have that moment where
it's like we should all just stab Caesar
I thought Melisandre would be care
because she's like you know it's like
I'm just aching or something but she is
a psychic but she keeps [ __ ] it up if
anybody was to check the weather by
rubbing their boobs it would be
Melisandre I think Aaron Samuels
is Robb Stark Aaron Samuels is like the
token generic like attractive guy the
same way Robb Stark is like the least
interesting of the Starks I don't know I
always equated Jon Snow to Aaron Samuels
just as they seem to be everybody's love
interest
I don't think Aaron Samuels would give
up his life for his people he does try
though when Katy gets her purse stolen
he chases after the bad guy Jon Snow
took a knife through the heart Aaron
Samuels chased after the purse I would
argue that Jon Snow is Tina Fey doesn't
care about being cool she doesn't care
about popularity fitting in all she
cares about is doing what's best for the
students same way Jon Snow doesn't care
about titles or popularity he just cares
about saving all the living people what
do you guys think about genius i right
off the bat thanks Damien Experion
couldn't agree more yep he's a bit of an
outcast he'll always like tell you the
truth and then yeah somebody who was
maybe friends was Thursday at one point
Janice and Regina were friends right
when they were like in middle school or
something so I think to be Baroness
since he kind of switched sides Janice I
think is an aria Susan through the
badass doesn't care what other people
saying yeah if we had a leeway to like
move things around
who would Sam's be she's had it rough
and then now she's like really yeah but
she's had it rough but she hasn't done
anything that's what bothers me I think
she's gone through a transformation she
has and so she's changed and she grew
and she became her own person she has
been kind of like a sidekick to Jon Snow
and is potentially starting to betray
Jon Snow much akin to a Gretsch in the
universe that wouldn't be my pick
progression but if we're trying to find
someone for something it's hard because
she still hasn't really done anything
like you said Glenn Cocco Rhaegar
Targaryen cuz he's somebody we hear a
lot about especially lately and we
haven't quite seen yet he's like
Daenerys his oldest brother who died
before the show began Jon Snow's father
so it came in
Denarius book it's kind of like you know
that's his aunt Karen was [ __ ] your
cousin right exactly those incest the
Mean Girls Wow so is this a thing good
game of thrones B Mean Girls there are
parallels Mean Girls is clearly a
prequel to Game of Thrones
you know nothing Tina Fey I don't know
how to end this I know but um incest
[Music]